STEPHANIE WONG:
Hi, I'm Stephanie.
And today we're going to look
at how you can build a real time
inventory management system
using Google Cloud Spanner.
Consumers are more digitally
connected than ever before.
Expectations for omnichannel
shopping experiences
across online and offline
channels have increased.
Experiences like buy
online, pickup in store
are expected now, rather than
considered a convenience.
For a company like Maxim
Modish, a fictional retailer,
in-person shopping has been the
backbone of their retail model
for years.
As a premier retailer, they have
hundreds of department stores
across the nation.
But to meet increasing
online demands,
they've had to undergo a
digital transformation.
In recent years,
Maxim Modish customers
have been engaging with them
through multiple channels,
online through social
media, in-store, and in app.
Naturally, these customers
expect a seamless experience
across all of these channels.
To better meet
these expectations,
Maxim Modish needed a complete
picture of their inventory flow
and real time decision
making at scale.
This revealed three
key challenges
they faced with their
technology stack.
One, inconsistent view
of data across silos.
Two, cost inefficiencies
to management overhead
and seasonal scaling needs.
Three, an inability to evolve
with new business needs.
This was a tough
problem to solve.
They were dealing with an
extremely large amount of data
requiring them to integrate
event data from hundreds
of siloed data sources
in a timely manner.
These inventory events
were coming in rapidly
and constantly
changing, resulting
in a lack of
real-time consistency
across data sources.
For example, a woman's
dress would show in stock
on the mobile shopping app,
but the same dress showed out
of stock in the physical store.
Additionally, running
their existing
on-premise infrastructure led
to numerous cost inefficiencies.
To keep up with the
growing volume of data
and meet seasonal scaling
during times like black Friday,
they had to increase
their on-prem data center
for peak capacity, which
aggravated operational costs
and tied up resources
managing that infrastructure.
Last, they were unable to
evolve with new business needs.
Running antiquated
systems, it was
difficult to adapt or
modernize their applications.
Applying changes to
monolithic systems
is a long, arduous process.
This is where Google Cloud
helped turn things around.
Through their
partnership, Maxim Modish
was able to build an inventory
ledger solution with Google
Cloud Spanner at its core.
This inventory
ledger solution is
modeled based on retail
environments represented
as a series of events.
These events include
things like items
shipped to a store, item price
updates, or customer purchase
requests.
They chose Spanner to
house their inventory event
ledger, which would keep
track of the constant changes
to inventory.
Cloud Spanner is
a managed database
with strong consistency in
regional and multi-regional
setup, no downtime,
and scale insurance.
It combines the best of
relational semantics and scale.
In addition, Spanner
is a managed service,
which frees Maxim Modish
from operational overhead
of their own large
scale inventory systems.
Whenever an inventory
event happens,
it's placed in an append-only
immutable event ledger.
This guarantees
inventory changes
are recorded in the
system consistently
across multiple regions.
As customers buy items
across different channels,
in-store or mobile, Spanner
gives them a consistent view
of the inventory no matter what
region or channel the shopper
comes from.
All replicas of the
inventory ledger
are kept up to date, in-sync,
and quickly available.
What's more, data
housed in Spanner
is easily available to other
Google Cloud Services, making
it simple for Maxim Modish
to leverage capabilities
like BigQuery for
SQL base analytics,
Looker for modeling
and reporting,
and AutoML and
BigQuery ML to apply
machine learning for smarter
real-time decision making.
For example, Maxim Modish
is able to integrate
BigQuery to create
this Looker dashboard.
They can conduct
further analysis
using BigQuery as a managed
data warehouse and Looker
for interactive visualizations
across all stores.
By implementing this
inventory ledger solution
with Cloud Spanner,
Maxim Modish now
has real-time view of inventory
across hundreds of data sources
and applications, the
ability to scale up and down
to support peak traffic
during large shopping events,
manage services which
significantly decreases burdens
of operations, and the
ability to modernize
and adapt to new business
needs through an ecosystem
of integrated cloud services.
By leveraging just some of the
powerful features of Google
Cloud, Maxim Modish is now able
to do real-time decision making
for omnichannel retail and build
a seamless online and offline
shopping experience for
thousands of happy customers
using a single source of truth.
Check out the link here to
learn more about Spanner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]